okay for people who are joining this
live stream we are looking at some image
and video functionality for the next
version Wolfram language and I had a
home internet disaster so I am at a
local office and different computers and
everything but hopefully things will
work okay um all right let's see we are
starting off with image and image 3d now
I assume I don't know if my just check
something here so I'm running 12-1 the
non prototype build a 12-1 right if you
have it well I have something I have no
idea if it's the right prototype build i
wasn't that wasn't I I wasn't told I
needed that so we may have to watch
somebody else's screen let's see whether
this is a useful modern prototype build
October 10th prototype build is that
useful or not that's useful video is
broken in yes their day today's
prototype build anyways so okay alright
so let's take a let's start off with the
image with annotation rules so can is a
demo here or what documentation I I
don't know if I can even get to that I
mean so you andhaka tools or in the
product okay so allocation rules okay so
what is the right hand side of
annotation rules and where does it say
what it is if you look at image annotate
you're gonna see the syntax as we were
we would like to support
so it's either gonna be a list of
regions or a region goes to value and
regions are anything like points to the
regions 3d regions for image 3d and so
forth
oh that should be a italic the word
names get out there I don't understand
this so wait a minute the right hand
side so the left hand side is a name of
that tag
so that is the the tag name and the
right-hand side is the specification of
where that tag is being put now how does
that relate to what we're doing for
graphs for how annotation works with
graphs the annotation rules the inner
the annotation rules specification is
similar they're they're called item that
the where is an item you know here it's
a region of interest it says where but
in there in the graphic case don't we
have the the graph annotate doesn't it
take the graph and there is no what does
it think Oh what's it called there is a
notation about entertain on an invisible
to annotate there's annotate than
there's annotation value okay so
annotate is taking an object
specification and name of the annotation
arrow value-laden yeah okay so this is
that or that first case that means that
that annotation is at the whole object
level I understand part one here right
that's for some part of it exactly but
so in this case why isn't this looking
like image comma item spec
as the first argument here and then name
our value I don't understand you see
what I'm saying
yeah so this has been that's what I'm
saying as we tried to extend it to new
domains then people come back and say
this is what we feel is really
comfortable and nice for images and this
is what's come back here have this nice
specification or nicer easier
specification of items this is a vertex
this is this is an edge this is a face
for image audio it's typically a lot
easier to specify a region of interest
as an interval bounding box the specific
point and so forth and then you
typically have a bunch of notes so you
want to say my face tag appears in these
five bounding boxes more comfortable way
of specifying annotations okay but I
don't think it was gonna work with these
this I mean okay so hold on a second so
the basic point is but you know I could
say for a graph I want to annotate a
thousand vertices right so how do I do
that with annotate well I think that the
item spec can be a multi you know spec
thing alright well what about the value
in the case of image annotate why aren't
you saying you know for example let's
say the tag is dog but I want some
payload like the probability that that's
a dog you know someone saying that's not
contained in your current image annotate
is it their value can be an association
I think I was mention which value there
isn't a value here there's only a name
here there's no value there is a name
and spec spec can be a ROI goes to value
so for value you can specify just a
probability or an association okay I
don't believe in this okay let's let's
roll this back a bit okay what you're
saying here
okay so for annotate you're saying there
is an object it has a single name value
thing associated with it okay for each
object there's a single name value
things if you want to multi annotate
that is you want a a single core object
okay so look to me this this seems like
these are incompatible right and you
know to me if you did something like
this where you said you know XXX
annotate and then there's the core
object and then there's essentially the
let's take the simplest case there's the
item spec and then there's the either
the single name or there is the payload
which will be named arrow value right
although that will that will that will
do the right thing automatically it
doesn't need the brackets but then if
you have a multi item specification you
could say here item 1 2 3 goes to named
arrow value or you could also allow I
don't think you necessarily want list of
all syntax there like you get what I'm
saying ace for easier like in that
example that you had with probabilities
that each item is going to have a
separate value oh yeah okay fine
so so that she does a very easy way to
do that and by the way this also
dovetails with the way that we need to
check that this dovetails but I think
that's going to work fine I think it's
going to work fine but they're going to
be two ways round depending whether
you're using an association
okay and it's just like.how classified
works you might want to get somebody
from is there anybody who knows the
machine learning the way that classifies
set up nobody in this meeting who knows
that as far as their sin taxes yes some
taxed yeah okay all right okay so fine
so then this is the alternative case
right this is the many items all in the
same annotate right see what I'm saying
yeah
okay so let's walk through what's the
other case of graph annotation Roger
what's the other function that's used in
graph annotation in addition to annotate
that is an annotation value okay fine so
let's look at annotation value okay so
now is annotation value also something
works with images I think not right what
does that image annotate return this one
is returning an annotated image an image
that has annotation rules baked into it
and the annotation rules as part of the
image yes okay and and and and annotate
returns a graph with annotation rules as
part of the graph correct that's right
okay all right fine okay so let's look
at I think we're going to get this okay
let's look at annotation value for a
second okay okay so the only thing
that's screwy here i seeso annotation
value wants to take I mean this item
spec name so we could have annotation
value of object and then item spec arrow
name no and then it's just items back no
I mean yeah equals value right so that's
one of the cases work for annotation
value that what annotation value is
pulling out the value object on the
right hand side of the name silver this
case here where it's just an item spec
and a tag is not really a case covered
by annotation value for graphs is that
correct
what do you mean by that I mean it will
return value in that case no what I'm
saying is in the case of an image you
want to tag a piece of an image as Fred
or Jane or whatever you know what I'm
saying mmm right so no value but it's
just a list of regions yes yes okay so
what's the analog of that in a gras you
might want to tag certain vertices
purely with their adding that there
hasn't been such an analogue it all had
to have some value okay so I think that
there's an argument that there should be
the concept of a naked tag which after
all we do have and and this is where in
fact something that came up yesterday is
the analog between you know a tagged
edge right and what's the difference
between a tagged edge and an annotated
edge and edge with annotation rules sir
I'm saying well
the tag better follow a lot I mean it's
much tighter integration could one in
principle went by forcing you to access
everything but the tag needs to be there
very tightly bound all right so let's
talk about what a tag is versus what an
annotation is okay a tag lives with its
host object in a sense is what you're
saying
mm-hmm when you do an operation on the
grass the tag for an edge follows along
with that edge when the edge is
reprocessed in some way for a graph
Union or whatever else it is right right
what happens to the annotation rules do
they follow along or not well so that's
what we added in 11:3 actually in 12
sorry which was with property lots of
annotation right and that many of them
will be now preserved I mean most of
them will be preserved as you do
operation they're a bad thing right okay
so so the issue is what we want so in
the case of a vertex in a graph how do
you add in the same way that we have
this notion of a tagged edge right so
here we have an we have don't we have a
tag oh gosh wait a minute what edge
attack okay
so remind me
that works that is I see okay so it's
edges were packing okay so I could say 1
goes to 2 3 goes to 4 3 goes to 4 goes
to 1 whatever it is right arrow ABCD
correct okay and if I say they're edge
labels arrow automatic this is so pretty
weird how do I get just that what we
agreed yesterday that is not what's
gonna happen right right then your build
is from the 10th of October so causality
wise this is 10 days before today I know
it probably hasn't what I'm after today
so there is a casaba budget time goes in
one direction even though I know that I
know I'm making these in fact one of the
things I have to do tonight with the
grass system is make causal network
graphs which illustrate precisely that
issue and and the various deviations
from that but I understand your point
goodi'm okay in any case the concept
here is those tags of a look at the
structure I'll see a bunch of tagged
edges is that correct yeah if I were to
look at the input form of this no oh
well let's say I don't know input form
can be whatever he wants
yes apparently there there yes okay you
know I've been
stuffin hypergraphs recently so I
actually understand those reasonably
well and we're going to regret this one
layer thing here I think I think it
would have been better to put those in a
list because that will immediately
generalize to the hydrographs case I
think that probably better be a hyper
edge or something
fine fine I mean is there a good reason
why those three things are flat as
opposed to a sub lister I don't feel
that strongly but I'm just asking the
question I think that then you need sort
of an adder I mean it's I don't know I
mean it's it's no I mean it I don't
think that there's a super good reason
to add extra layer or list or not have
it okay well all right okay I could
really raise that with Charles it's
Charles him and you know this meeting
but okay can we can we make sure to
raise that please so Andrea could you
make a note of that so we make sure to
raise it um okay bow there a question
from Brian my live stream when little
annotations
not be preserved basically when the
graph has been reprocessed and spat out
again and I just warm right Roger it's
it's it's complicated and it's it's when
you I wish I could sort of give you a
finite set of rules exactly when it well
but I can say one thing when the thing
has been reconstituted let's say you do
a grass intersection okay and there's
one set of annotations from one place
where certain edges are coming from
another set of annotations but the other
place where the edges are coming from
what are you going to do yeah
one says read the other says green what
are you gonna do yeah
that's exactly the case those are the
exactly the kinds of things where it's
not right so in that case what we're
choosing to do is throw them both away
is that correct we're not trying to have
a merging of annotations we're just
throwing them away that's right so let
me make a comment about that okay which
i think is going to come up with other
annotations in the case of associations
we have a whole notion of merging
functions right because you've got two
associations and a given key can only
support a single value right the
question is what do you do right and
there's a notion of merging functions
and I suspect that's what we could have
in this case for those more complicated
operations we know so we've thought
about that and maybe we should introduce
that but I think it's at this point it's
over complicating something I agree I
agree I think that's where we're going
and as we look at other kinds of
annotations for other things we may want
to bear that in mind because they may
need that yeah but I think it's example
if you think Amodeo an image are very
far from even trying to preserve any
kinds of notations at this point I
understand so when you do an image
compose you blow away all the
annotations true statement yes
so if you stitch two images together
what is that operation called when when
you have an image you just literally
putting an image to the right of it or
something images and oh okay I'll be
getting rid of annotations and image
Istanbul Tarantino's there is no
annotation calculus for images are not
you so with any operation they are
removed but for reading moving around
assembling and calculus of annotation is
trivial that can be implemented I think
that would be nice I think you're gonna
appreciate that right um
let's see question from Brian our live
stream are the rules for the annotation
calculus documented no Roger no I mean I
don't even know how you would document
the rules well I mean you can say this
function does not preserve annotations
this one dot yes that that should surely
be documented yes we should probably add
statements to say what to what extent
annotations are preserved by this this
operation of that operation fine sounds
sensible to me including just the a
blanket statement this operation does
not preserve annotation and putting that
in a bunch of places is fine yeah
Sandra our live stream says there should
definitely be an annotation merging
function he thinks he can help us define
the calculus part it's it's some I
suspect it gets really hairy with graphs
and you know with some because it's
going to be what operation are you doing
how are they going to be combined blah
blah blah um so Brian is asking the
somewhat interesting question is it a
way to determine which annotations will
be discarded other than just trying it
and seeing I think that's going to be
really difficult I mean I think it's a
while ago if you want the more detailed
discussion exactly the details of the
current annotation calculus and I
wouldn't call it a calculus per se then
I think we should have Charles here why
don't we ask Charles to join us because
I think we're about to change some
aspects of the annotation design to
merge what's happening with the graphs
and images could somebody see a
candidate could you see itself
um okay so listen what I'm thinking here
is that we're really close I mean to
having these Beamer chable let's make
them merge able right between the image
annotate annotate annotation value
see what I'm saying um the main issue
the main difference here is the unvalued
tag if you understand what I'm saying
yeah Roger yes which we have an unvalued
tag in the case of images but not in the
case of graphs at the current time I
think that they have been added in the
case of graphs and their controls can
confirm the deadlines all right fine but
then I would propose that this be
supported as well as the just like for
um for um classify this way round
alright so we get the best of both
worlds we have both a named arrow item
spec warm and then I can spec arrow name
form yep okay and and particularly
that's useful when you pull out an
annotation
well actually hold on a second this is
not so easy because this oh look that's
for the tag type thing but then we've
got to have this right slightly more
exotic creature to represent the value
case right so in other words this which
is they came ready documented for image
annotate anyways right which case in the
table if you yeah that spec spec can
already be a Roy goes to value which is
item spec goes to value in your notebook
spec can be an item spec goes to value
okay fine but that's not an association
as I'm saying that case goes in an
association whereas this case
would be items Picaro name items back
our name our value mm-hmm so Charles
were trying to make a child with us yes
um so we're trying to make we're trying
to make sure we're compatible between
image annotation and graph annotation
okay and the main point of contention is
that in graph annotation there's this
notion of object comma item speck in a
list you know we could support all of
these syntaxes actually I mean there is
the simian image in audio is just the
way you look at it I know that not
correct the only respect is not part go
ahead for images more the wisdom of
centrists ogod hava now I'm with Charles
we're just talking about the syntax oh
okay the syntax is incompatible okay
because what you have for graphs
okay the graft case what you have right
now for graph is annotate in the kit
object comma item and then you have
named arrow value right and so what I'm
saying is what we need to do is make it
be the case and right now what we have
for image is essentially well we almost
have as object and then we have well
what I'm proposing is we have item arrow
named arrow value for the case that
you've described there okay now we could
allow the alternative form annotate but
we got to canonicalize these things in
some way object arrow item or even
exactly the form you have object I I'm
yeah object comma item and then named
arrow value I'm not particularly keen on
that but we could do that we could allow
that as well
I mean that might be nice that you can
just give a region of interest there
okay so Charles question in the case of
images we have pure tag annotation okay
no value as a payload what is the analog
of Latin cross we clearly have that an
edge tagged in a tagged edge but what is
the analog of the no value
tagging there is pacing no value tagging
if somebody want to simulate such a
thing he just have to put a default
value so it's all equivalent but we
don't support the no tagging value no
targets I think we should and you can do
that internally by having some well I
don't I don't care how you do it
internally but what I mean well but I
think we need that case I want to take a
graph I mean I in fact needed that case
just yesterday okay I'm trying to tag
okay I've got since Roger brought up
causal networks I have a I have a a a
graph and I'm trying to tag it with
events that correspond I'm going to tag
each vertex with the event it was its
creator event and destroyer event so
what you're saying is I should say
creator event arrow whatever it is but
okay let's say I only had one of those
to tag with I wouldn't mind being able
to just give that as a tag I mean the
issue is it will be better to have a
default name but to have the value be
the be the tag so to speak see what I'm
saying rather than to have a and
similarly for images it might be better
to have a pure tag I don't know I don't
know you get what I'm saying
shotty other people for image
compression yeah go ahead
question is if you are going to have a
pure tag
is it better to say you know default tag
arrow whatever where the actual nature
of the tag the actual you know content
of the taggers and the value or is it
better to spray out lots of names and
Charles has tried to avoid spraying out
lots of names right and instead said put
all the content in the value so the
analog of that for image will be to say
that the case item arrow name is not a
real case right that item arrow that
here that annotate object item arrow
name is actually equivalent to um you
know annotate object item arrow
automatic arrow name or something or
default or something like that our name
you get what I'm saying did you get what
I'm saying I don't
what's that default tag it seems like
you're getting the value the value is
missing there right no no no no there's
no value missing this when I'm saying
name let me put the name in quotes okay
because that name is being treated as a
value the thing that you were Lemmy's
right tag okay do you see what I'm
saying yep that tag instead of saying
instead of saying I'm going to annotate
an image by spraying in an elephant a
rhinoceros a pig a chicken whatever it
is right as names I'm gonna say those
are default tags because I couldn't be
bothered you know I could equally well
have said you know animal arrow and then
chicken you know cow whatever it is
right you get what I'm saying yep
but you're saying because I'm being a
little bit lazy I want to use a tag that
is an unnamed tag to go what I'm saying
yeah I see what but then at the same
time we want unnamed tags and then we
want value less tags I mean oh no - Adi
that's not correct there are no
valueless tags in this case all tags
have a value as they do in Charles's
system it's simply the things that you
were thinking of as being pure tags
right that don't have values are now the
values of unnamed tag or we could call
it tag if you want to whatever it is
right that they are the value of tag
okay what I'm saying yep Charles you
were gonna say something yes I mean if I
call correctly I mean there was one of
the case where we had a annotate on the
thought was to have some you know from
the last meeting have some custom
function equivalent to a notate but
which have a more friendly syntax for
those different object like for your
image I don't care I don't care listen
listen this is the song okay what
because also there is a notation holes
where is whether you do that clear
distinction between the name value and
the tag where you store them you know in
a more efficient way you don't spray
them okay look what happened here so in
the case of a graph is item name value
and we compress them like that where if
you look at the case for audio
is it time yeah it's a name item value
values okay so this is the total mess
guys he's not in this is movies that
were an additional is more that option
we carry for serialization which is not
a c-stand
alright okay so then let me make a
comment about this okay
it's just like you know okay if it is
purely for serialization you've got to
tag it somehow so the code that goes in
and looks at the annotation rules well I
mean look we've got tagging rules which
we use in notebooks which similarly it's
kind of cesspool of different structures
right but okay look what I propose you
can shoot this down but what I propose
is that we standardize on something I
mean you know we standardize on
something which where everything is a
name value is a key value pair basically
okay now the default key we can talk
about what that is and whether we need
to actually include it but basically
everything is a key value pair am I
making sense all annotations are in the
form of key value pairs do you agree do
you disagree okay shorty and then we'll
have to see where the item specs go
right so name annotation name item spec
could be the key or the key is always
the annotation name and value is a
combination of items they can value or a
potential value is a very disorienting
I'm sorry too
go ahead what we say I'm saying I think
that discrepancy here is whether we are
where we are specifying item specs or
region of interest sometimes it starts
with the object like that annotate case
that we have object from item and in the
image all your case we are putting it we
are saying name goes to items oh yeah I
know so we have to unify these okay we
have to unify them and maybe we have
some syntactic you know freedom in this
in this thing okay so okay so we've got
this principle so now let's just go
through and look at what each one has to
do okay and we got to think about
annotate annotation value and annotation
rules is that correct is there anything
else we're thinking about so it's
annotate um let's see annotation value
and annotation rules there anything else
from that family name I'm sorry
annotation named yes okay okay so given
that we've got to have we got to do
something with these default name tags
right they've got to have some name um
okay fine that's useful
okay so annotation to leak is a by name
deletion is that correct yes can it be
you know I'm wondering with I think you
know we could also delete by item well
you can't leave by name globally or you
can't have the object item right is
always by name you delete on annotation
not the object yeah I understand
okay I am gonna suggest possibly
renaming annotation names dilatation
keys and having the notion so let's
explore the idea okay question could the
key value be unique F I'd keys would you
object to that that is given a
particular item it has a unique set of
keys right no key is duplicated yes is
that problematic that's okay as far as
you're concerned yes yep okay so fine so
then an annotation could be conceptually
a Association right so we start off with
the annotation okay so here's what we're
thinking about so then the annotation is
it is associated with a particular item
okay so this is the annotation for a
given item is an association of that
form make sense so then now what we have
to say is what so this gives us a
structure so this is saying that we want
to be able to say item arrow and then
it's a sock there so then we could say
things like plural items item 1 item 2
arrow a sock and that would be a way of
saying in for these functions like
annotate this item gets this association
right that makes sense that's not going
to be the useful syntax for image all
you you rarely want to have a single
position goes to an a saw and then you
would unless then then you look at this
case it's thanking what you want
that's fine all good no problem that
that will be the typical case for images
right right okay so now in the case of
annotation value okay hold on let me
think about this for a second so in the
case of annotation value what you want
to get out you've got the object you've
got the item and then the value so then
it'll say item arrow key and that will
be what the thing that that will then
give a value right and possibly if you
have a list of items there it can give a
list of values right make sense
okay so now yes I mean my only kissable
object is that it's more convenient to
attach the objects to the item in our
case because hold on we're not there yet
I'm not telling you you can't do that
yet okay
explain why it's more convenient well
this is what the way you actually think
about it it's you know is the following
act you know an item of a text of a calf
and then you want the given Association
but you don't essentially disassociate
the graph on the item especially that
since when we introduced those proper to
annotation at the time right we didn't
have Association so in those case you
are essentially writing a list of Falls
and it was kind of odd to have item key
and then also you have the key value by
rope that's the part we're now building
rebuilding because we're not there's not
called property anymore it's called
annotation so to do whatever we want
right okay so the issue is whether
something like that makes any sense
I only might be able to support that I
mean one I mean I don't know what you
wanted to be listable with respect to
objects do you but the one thing that
puzzles me is that how are we gonna deal
with items that are intersecting with
the actual items that are stored in
image audio annotations so you may have
a bounding box if you get a point that
lands on that bounding box should that
be should that bounding box be returned
or no things like that I'm not sure I
don't know what you're talking about why
does that relate to this
well as the syntax of annotations yep
okay that's a different issue well we
are extracting annotation values yeah
that's a separate issue yes okay so that
form or the list form we have to decide
between those right but I don't see any
reason you can't support that makes
sense Charles but that is essentially
exactly what you have now is this form
here right yes okay now let's look at
annotate okay so annotate in the second
form would be Chiara value which is what
you have right now right but we are
proposing that we also allow annotate
object item arrow key arrow value right
or that we're allowing annotate object
well so there various forms here that
comma a sock which is multi key so what
I'm saying
Anna Kate let's see what would it be
object comma yeah
item arrow a sock right those were both
work making sense yes you understand yes
okay so the one thing we're not covering
here is so I think this covers
everything I think have to work it
through
okay so annotation rules would then
canonicalize okay by the way
station keys you'd be able to say object
arrow item or you'll be able to say keys
object comma item presumably it's a
little weird that both of those work but
them okay okay yeah that makes sense
there is a case which we have you know
when it when the those are at the object
level itself but not in some part of it
so it's a global property they're not in
some heart like for the whole graph as
opposed to some order X reg end okay and
so right now if you look at the annotate
EDS has basically annotate object name
value so that's kind of at the global
level okay well let me point out how you
could do that here we could use another
we could call itself if we want you
don't need to do that you don't need to
do it it works just fine with just that
that's not an ambiguous syntax sure yeah
the way I've been thinking about it is
that meta information is the option that
stores global metadata annotation rules
is the local self that has item spec or
region of interest that's not how it
works with graphs so they both the
global and the local yes that ambiguity
that we have what we call standard
annotation but which are object
associated to attach to the OP to the
you know the option attached to the
object right okay what would happen if
annotation rules canonicalize to an item
arrow a sock is that bad is that good
does anybody object to that it's fine
for graph I think the issue is for other
object you know is the way you are going
to store it it may be inefficient item
of story okay sorry
that's for you it's also going to be
inefficient for images well what is it
there's no also child said it was fine
for grass but he said it might not be
fine for other things I'm also thinking
how about there takes something like
vertex style you're gonna have one goes
tube and then all of those a Sox are
going to have vertex tile goes to
something is that that's also not
efficient okay fine fine all right okay
okay so then then this could be I mean
yeah those keys is gonna be repeated a
zillion a times it has it has to be
handled object in graph we can't store
it you know if it's very text the way
you stop a textile is not a similar
object x coordinate the vertex
coordinates are pack structure in some
cases on most of the case time machine
stuff you store them differently yeah
okay fine so store it this way score it
like that
that's consistent with what we're doing
up here right that's the item arrow a
sock form and in this form here we
should be able to say item 1 item 2
arrow a sock
so like Brian is commenting on on the
live stream that if you wanted to
annotate every endless image as being an
8 or something you could do that like
this the thing I don't think would be
easy is how would i annotate all faces
with approximated age of that face my
items are gonna be a bunch of bounding
rectangles and then the key is gonna be
h or facial age and the values are gonna
good so i have to specify separate item
goes to age goes to value you're not
gonna have any choice you've got it
you've got two different things that are
varying right yep so the only thing you
would be able to do is is if you wanted
to have something that says age arrow
you want to have a different way round
so this is analogous to image
interleaving yeah an image IMTA leaving
right sometimes you want it one way
sometimes you want it the other way so
talk about how that's worked out for
every process side how do we deal with
that for interleaving we have that we
have the option in the image object okay
so one could imagine I mean
unfortunately here you know one could
imagine that the annotation rules could
be stored in a different form if they
were tagged appropriately right so
you've got these different forms you
could say age arrow and then you've got
item one arrow blah you know item to our
blah right so you're saying that all
possible
factorings of this makes sense am i
making sense or parcel factorings of the
annotation rules or possible you know
column row orderings etc um you know
right
by the way brian is suggesting on a live
stream and i agree that the way to pull
up the whole object annotation is just
annotation value and that may already
work annotation value of object pulls up
the whole object annotation right make
sense it could alternatively return all
of the annotations associated to all of
the what is the whole object annotation
we have to define what is a notation you
know in the case of a graph is it aver
textile or is it just on given by the
user I don't know no I think if its
whole object is nothing that can be
broken down on to the parts what I mean
is that by the inheritance question of
whether where the vertex style on the
whole object is inherited by the parts
or not and if somebody specified graph
vertex goes to word do I have to
instantiate it for every single vertex
no hopefully not I mean you don't right
now do you know we don't ok so question
is annotation rules a user visible thing
in other words could we store a bunch of
crud in annotation rules that is
optimized for column ordering row
ordering whatever and not have the user
have to worry about it
in the plan of graph it was the case
that no the only time we use annotation
hole was
essentially for the inheritance and
certain serialization realization ok so
then I've got a proposal let's let's put
it for image audio so far it's been a
visible well with audio it's been
released and it's a visible option it
gets stored no no it was still visible
visible in that sense but it wasn't
promoted as something that you would
mess with drum saying right so what we
could have is you know in principle
annotation rules could look like this at
the top level and you can optimize it
however you want
right but depending on the object under
way we want to store it and if you want
to display so long as so long as we have
converters which we could easily do
between you know let's say we have three
storage schemes and we have converters
between those storage schemes and if
somebody put it in a different storage
scheme you can convert it when you need
to ingest it for something it's all good
I mean you know in a sense this is very
similar to the issue for data set about
column-oriented storage for data set I
don't know what we're doing there I
think there is a plan for that and you
should understand what that is so that's
a Chris Coulson issue I think have any
of you do any of you know what the story
is there okay
so Andrea that's another thing has to be
connected here so maybe shadi you could
interact with with them with Chris and
whoever else is dealing with that issue
you understand this I mean maybe Jose
knows about that the issue is that
there's an inefficiency right now the
exact same reason you're bringing up
here in data set if the data set
consists of a list of identical
associations that's a waste of storage
not a big waste of storage it's just a
pointer for each thing but okay but the
other thing is that you're also likely
to get kind of sparse
[Music]
yeah that's come to my point like in the
case of guff I don't see how we are
going to document because the way we
store ver textile and vertex coordinate
are different in mesh the way we store
markers are different on the way we
store information about each polygon
okay listen listen Charles so what
you're saying is you are just putting
non-user understandable stuff in the
annotations in these cases is that
correct is used understandable if we
want to document it let's just choose no
I'm not sure that we do I'm not sure we
do I mean it could just be something but
that's why I know one actually I know
that for how many years mean what that I
mean for I don't know more than five
generally stuff no one actually
requested to manipulate them because
from the construct of the cuff you don't
really need to go and dig inside the
object for that I understand that so
maybe we need to make it in app a Cobb
jekt but you know an annotation rules
object
you know that's possible that just
prints us some nice blob
and you know and really is opaque so I'm
saying so the storage is there we do it
in a way that's good for us and we don't
you know we don't worry that the poor
user with how it works I think they'll
be perfectly acceptable shoddy any
objection to that idea that would be
fine for us because we are storing
everything on there annotation rules
okay Roger your comments yeah I mean I
don't think it has been a problem what
we've had so far
oh I understand that I understand that
so we either can have something which is
a mess and undocumented we can actually
hide it inside that baked object I don't
really care about those two
possibilities yeah
annotation rules is not intended to be
an end user modifiable or understandable
thing right just like sparsa way if you
look at its full form you yeah chunk
right I mean you can you can if you
really commit it you can understand it
but it's also likely to change in which
case you will be host okay but kinda if
we think this might change we should
have a versioning we should have it
inside no cake object version yeah I
would sort of prefer the opaque object
and I think it might be useful for other
purposes anyway okay so let's loop back
here so I mean I think we've got a at
least much of a plan here I think it
would be worthwhile to go through this I
mean I may have missed some cases here
but I think we've got something
reasonably nice here
anybody object just one thing to confirm
currently graphs and meshes put a lot of
the specified annotations on there other
options this opaque object is that
really going to work in those cases say
that again
like things like the vertex tiles that
get stored actually under the
american-style
option those are not going to be
included in the annotation rules object
those are going elsewhere currently are
we planning
to keep them all together or no so we
had the notion of standard annotations
you know which are basically like
options to the object itself those are
the things that are well supported but
the other important case is sort of
user-created ones whatever you want to
call them I know but shaadi is asking do
you pull the vertex style into the
annotation rules object or not yeah I
kind of think not but similar
x-coordinate on all do anything which is
the fine that's fine okay there I don't
think so those are simply not
annotations you're asking what are
annotations those are not annotations
don't understand no no I don't think you
should say that I think that will just
confuse people the problem is those are
not annotations they okay with what
would we call them then used favorite
thing so annotation value is capable of
handling vertex style exactly it's
anonymous yesterday yeah you do they
know that I know that all right so
annotation rules okay the Meher let me
make a suggestion then annotation rules
has essentially an automatic tentacle
which just says in effect oh and by the
way also pull in all the things that
just come from options I mean then we're
okay then we're conceptually fine am I
making sense annotation value notation
rules because all of those standards no
no no no no no no no no let's do what
I'm saying I'm saying annotation rules
because it does not
tane the vertex style you know what it
has to do is to include by reference
things like vertex style okay
the concept is here's the flow
annotation value looks at annotations
that's what the that's the official
documented behavior okay
annotation value is digging into
annotation rules okay but annotation
rules is saying but I'm also referencing
the standard annotations to see what I'm
saying I'm automatically including the
standard annotations they see an
additional value doesn't affect one
rotation calls because like in the case
I know but I okay listen listen
annotation value the answer would say
annotation value gets annotations from
annotation rules okay you say bleep
bleep what about vertex style right
I say annotation rules has an automatic
or something case which automatically
pulls in the standard annotations you
see what I'm saying that's the
conceptual flow so for other functions
if they want something
I mean annotation rules has an automatic
case which automatically pulls in and
might list them and might actually list
them ie you know vertex style whatever
else right so in other words in the
annotation rules object it would say
sort of conceptually kind of local data
local rules and then it might say the
list of its standard annotations is that
I'm saying
blah blah blah okay and here it might
say something like some specific rules
or something whatever it is key value
makes sense
so then conceptually what we're saying
is it all goes through annotation rules
but annotation rules pulls in certain
standard annotations by default now
nobody will ever mess with this but in
principle you could change that and say
actually I don't want vertex style as
part of the standard annotations
although nobody will ever do that does
that make sense to people yes I quite
like this I think this design is getting
there okay so with this design there is
no need for image annotate it's gone
correct
the one thing that may be useful is the
future eyes note that they have in their
short card for adding some annotations
some name Danity okay okay I agree that
would be useful
so in principle image annotate could be
a slightly more ergonomic version of
annotate it happens to have some
shortcuts where images right but
conceptually it would work exactly the
same as all these other ones right so it
would allow things like I mean you know
in principle we might want image
annotate and we could say of an image
and what you have in mind is things like
faces arrow ages yep
yeah I agree that that might be useful
to have an image annotate as a separate
thing while supporting the syntax of
annotate but maybe or maybe not maybe
maybe it's just those custom annotations
that are available there
so Brian on the livestream asked another
question which is a bulk removal of
annotations so for example like just
blow away all annotations how do you do
that so I think that will be part of
annotation delete okay so let's let's
look at that case do we look at that
here okay so annotation delete of an
object would presumably blow away all
the annotations of the object is that
right yes what does standard and again
the standard edition are initialized
automatic or the default value if you
say annotation delete yes so if it's a
stand and additional like vertex style
is set to automatic okay alright so then
the only other case is the deletion what
is the second argument what you have
here is the key basically is the second
argument and what that means is so let's
let's be clear about what that means
because what that really means that's
one case the other one here will be all
arrow key okay that's the equivalent of
this that that is equivalent to all
arrow key and the alternative is to say
item arrow key or a list of items am I
making sense yes so what you don't get
there is okay so let's just walk through
this for a second because the next case
would be item arrow key or item arrow
all which means delete or blank which
means delete every annotation associated
with that item makes sense yes
okay there's one last thing we need to
handle here which is default annotation
right do we have so shorty wants purely
a tag without a key put purely a value
without a key right no she could say a
key without value yes keep it all the
value okay whatever you want I mean I it
doesn't really matter what you're saying
that because either one is messy okay so
you say okay all right so this is the
case keys without values what happens so
let's take a look at some of these some
taxes so I suppose we could have
annotate object this is going to be
ambiguous it's going to be ambiguous
okay we've got object arrow item and
then just a naked key okay but we can't
have chiara value there because that's
ambiguous oh we don't need a key r-value
because it has no value
I'm sorry we can't have item arrow value
because that's ambiguous see what I'm
saying right but object arrow item comma
key like what you have there just works
no that's enough for why can't have okay
limit we can't have
can't have this annotate object item
arrow key because it's ambiguous with
versus chiaro value now notice that the
Chiara value is actually a shorthand for
an association but if we allow that
short term we can't have item arrow key
I don't think that's devastating okay
now if you were to extract the key value
Association in this case what would you
see because an association can't have a
naked key so it would have to be key
arrow automatic probably for the default
key right and finding this is why I'm
not certain that you're right that you
want it to be a key because finding the
default tag is a mess I mean it would be
anywhere a mess you'd have to know its
name if you've got several named tags
that are you know where the names are
meaningful and you've got this one well
I mean you can always do it by
convention the other way I think that's
okay if you really want to do it this
way that's okay although how you know
that that's the default key I have no
idea how you know that's the default key
as opposed to a key that happens to our
value automatic so I bet you're gonna
need a function that is is the key
present 0 I'm saying does it have a
given key there's a particular thing now
we can't do a notation value or turn
missing noticing about something
sensible
well actually key missed missing key
annotation value goes to missing
key absent I think as there is the term
well done okay well for an annex for an
association there is a similar concept
right for an association there's the
concept of when of how you test whether
a particular key exists key member - I
think keys askew let so be very good
okay so it will be key exists q of
annotation value of object comma you
just see if I can understand what to do
here
okay okay all right so it's this it's
key exists q of that would tell you
whether so it will retrieve the whole
Association for that annotation for that
item in the object and then it will do a
key exists q on that that makes sense
brian is suggesting the slightly wild
idea of using the object itself as the
value in the case in the default key
case I don't really believe in that I
think that's fraught with horror of oh
there happens to be a you know you can't
tell because that identity is not it
might be a coincidental identity okay
I'm pretty happy with this design can
you guys try and work it through and see
what corners there are yeah now let's
let's try and look at it again next week
if we can okay try to understand what
what might be the issues okay so let's
loop back here we've I think we should
keep going a bit we'll try to get some I
don't know exactly what I'm gonna have
to leave time get some I I mean I know
you've got quite a bit of stuff here so
let's take a look more I mean that was a
bit of a bump but I think we're through
it Roger are you happy I think that this
is okay I I it's sort of a begged for
this you know more thorough work through
I thought that we would launch one as
experimental and then we could have a
more sensible discussion but I think
this is pretty good I think what we've
got in this design is quite good i I
don't think it's gonna I don't think
there's a lot of holes here well I'll
see I mean actual use actual use makes a
big difference I understand but this is
what I think we should implement
basically this and you know it's really
just cosmetic changes to what we have
and take it from that sure okay just
before we move on we have had an audio
annotation look up and then we are
similarly developing image annotation
lookup which could mean it's more like
annotation value and I think maybe we
can go without a lookup function but one
thing there goes in in a lookup function
is to combine or process the annotations
as we go as well so either format them
combine them compute something on it and
so forth
unnecessary - for the first phase if you
think that's gonna complicate their
design I don't see the point I mean the
lookup function that we have the generic
lookup function does not do that so I
don't understand how something called
annotation lookup makes any sense for
doing that see it just does that yep
what it has is the possibility of
default if the key is not found which is
quite useful right right and that might
be useful for an annotation lookup as
well but I wouldn't put that in at the
beginning I would just have an
annotation value okay so what what else
four four okay so now we should look at
highlight image
so what's new here 12:1 a few thanks the
default color has changed labeling and
legend we're associating well I'm what
ways with default color changed to be
pink and some people don't think that's
an error message so remember that's been
a you know many people complain about
that
so it's gone gone to this more bluish
color feels like a good color to me
magenta thank you um looks good
ok image labels Wow how does that relate
to vertex labels no it's more related to
plot labels why this is for labeling and
legend thing if you're if you are
highlighting corners and key points with
two different colors and you want to get
either labels for them or legends for
them these are gonna be you yes there
should be examples if you scroll down
both on their scope labeling and legend
in there and there is work to be done to
get scrims for those labels and then
placement well that's nice that's a
nicer thing that's cool so then does it
also work with a call-out as well as
labeled an legend it should work and and
we didn't implement scrims here shoddy
what is grim scrim is is when it's sort
of half transparent invented for
smartphones because they're tight on
real estate the problem with it yeah you
know it's that it covers everything a
little bit of see-through goes a long
way for comprehension so yeah we use
scrims all the way and we should do that
here too obviously yeah which I'm sure
you can
with image processing right but this is
really nice I really like this this
concept of it labeled in an image that's
really cool okay legend did like cool I
see so this let me understand this
so this like so I mean like vertex
labels I'm a little confused here okay
help me out
so vertex labels requires the name of
the vertex on the left hand side and a
set of runes correct Charles yes okay in
this case you are simply having a
sequential list of graphics you know
geometric objects and then you're sort
of threading in that same list of labels
right that make sense yeah I'm not even
sure if you need to support this or if
it would be very useful to support that
in this in this particular I think it's
pretty marginal I mean I think the label
thing is very useful I think this is
kind of marginal and I wouldn't do this
I mean not initially I would I would
consider this but I wouldn't necessarily
do it um one other use
addition if you scroll a bit more off in
there
a bit of in the syntax specification
region of interest the label goes to
region of interest that first table see
the 12:1 plus is similar to what image
contents return and this you
automatically do labeling and legend
ding and so forth okay but that you
might be limit labels for to say what to
do it's automatic expressions or none
yep
what is their settings for image labels
image legends so you you are not
proposing to get rid of the image labels
you're proposing to leave the image okay
so here's let me make a suggestion the
list form of image labels could do that
sequential listing there can be an
association form of image labels which
says given the particular label right
here still presumably given a label here
that says tiger there could be a list of
regions of interest for tigers here yep
okay so then what you would do is image
labels as you'd say Association tiger
arrow whatever red or something right I
think that would work fine
that's what
I would propose so you're gonna need
image labels anyway yeah so in principle
you could end up with labels and legends
so you could set both labels and legends
to automatic in which case both would
show up correct okay that's some nice
functionality here very useful okay
what's an image Istanbul this was a very
simple function and used two failed for
any non conformed set of images now we
are we are becoming a bit more forgiving
with different color spaces big debts
and things like that we're also adding
spacings and some other options so are
you for adding fill in as well and that
is if the thing doesn't okay we can't
feel that scratch is there a fitting
option is there an option for fitting in
other places
no this fitting argument also is
available in image collage that's where
we got this from I don't know if you
have an option like that at least not
any mesh processing no you called
spacings is that an option that we oh it
is okay great
looks nice spacings so in other words
spacings defaults to zero correct and
what does it look like it looks like
some kind of weird window for anything
yeah it just adds padding it made me
scroll down to options spacings that's
the background color which is used both
for padding around or padding in between
the spacings okay that's nice enough
looks nice um okay image transformation
what what happened there it's just
faster transforms for now but we do like
that
what nonlinear transformation comes now
that's that's not for now needs more
work before we bring that up it sounds
like it's a general kind of thing it is
that's why it needs more work so so this
is simply as the speed increase there's
no functionality changes that correct
correct Brian our live stream is
pointing out that you'd mentioned shadi
that image assemble strips annotations
but if the individual images don't
overlap why delete them the question
being asked him and I agree with that
assemble doesn't need to I mean image
compose good luck but image assemble I
don't see why you shouldn't leave the
regions of interest with the you know
with the annotations intact right with
the shifted positions and all of that in
the new so that there is any some
minimal calculus that has to happen
hi sorry okay what were you saying here
I'm by the way we're having the people
from the next meeting which I think
includes Charles join this this one that
we might want to for the sake of the
livestream keeping that well okay all
right we'll survive we'll see how long
we have to go in this one okay all right
next up face the line and that's a new
function right there's a certain
ambiguity between human faces and
polyhedral faces haha maker on a live
stream is looking forward to nonlinear
transformations of images um okay face
alignment I say this is a face forward
so to speak that right not face forward
but isin typically its eyes and nose or
eyes and nose and mouth aligned it's no
there is no 3d no what do you mean by
line I don't know it's useful for any
kind of recognition or morphing and
things like that I'm totally confused
what is this doing let's let's take a
look at it sticks to eyes eyes and nose
in the same places they're aligned you
know it's amazing you know there's a
certain random contingency of biological
evolution that wound us up with you know
two eyes in the nose and more or less
that configuration and the fact that now
that becomes essentially a coordinate
system it's really kind of amusing but
anyway never mind you know were we to be
a different species you know if the
if the turtles had ruled the earth so to
speak we'd be doing a very different you
know there'd be some weird thing with
the center scale would be nevermind I'm
and I'm not going to get into kind of
what is it the shape-shifting lizards
theory
never mind um okay so what is this so
this is basically there's a triangle of
eyes two eyes and a nose type of thing
is that the idea
yep how you can specify more landmarks
to align and different transformation
classes to alone this is a prototype
field still I don't know um I'd like to
look at this look this is a complicated
function I mean I'm not quite sure what
so this is simply taking according to
the reference space raft so learnt list
of the specified size why isn't that
just an image size option what is the
size argument that's really weird why
isn't that an image size display size
for images oh that's the size of the
face that's the that's the size of the
dimensions pixel dimensions of the image
that comes back okay so what's the
analog of this in it if you look at
image Krim or something how is that
specifying the size of the final I
mentioned we have it image image trim
you give it a bunch of points or regions
and trims
around it returning it there is no
choice of resulting image size but for
instance image transformation has it and
we are using this size argument
image rotate hazard we have a size
argument all right what's the our women
to trim that just says make this image
such-and-such a sized image resize yeah
okay and you're going to say that does
the same thing okay
does this have a width only yes cutting
no boy okay so this so these are also
image key point key points that you can
pick out for faces right correct those
are new those are single point facial
features that we are adding in this will
release in facial features as well we
only used to have lists of point for
eyes what do you mean math if you open
facial features in 12 it didn't have
that set of key points and we're
introducing that in 12 one that's the
tenth of a table I see so left eyebrow
points will be multiple points whereas
this is left eye center center of those
points until we don't have left I left
point yeah so we have mouth left mouth
right since we happen to be a species
with a single mouth that you're not
Roger may be existing fair enough um boy
this is really you know we're not some
species equality is out the window here
yeah but it's prejudiced by our customer
place um okay I'm just thinking you know
if we were doing this for cats it will
be whisker left extent and so on upper
whisker what are those things called
above the cat what are those things with
the top gold then I'll call whiskers I
don't know what they call um okay
bounding whisker nevermind
um okay fair enough
all right facial features okay there you
would simply updating what was a lined
image property and that's for fine faces
since we have nicely iced tea okay so
that's paste the line and then this is a
lined image I see which is there which
is the face the line output for the face
correct
nice okay all right good good okay
video um oh by the way Nick along live
stream is asking its place the line
applying them I find transformation on
linear transformation it has a
transformation class option there is no
there there is no nonlinear
transformation function yet in the
system once we have more advanced things
like radial basis that's also going to
be supported that's the very last table
I think in face of my so those are
almost all of
I find and accept perspective is Lina
fractional come what is what users touch
nation close imagine line find your
metric transform image corresponding has
it been around has been around for a
while or is this new it's an awful name
I wish should have been called geometric
transformation class well I guess we
haven't had a collision yet okay I
didn't know that was the thing all right
onward video that's not like yeah that's
not 12 that's not going to be twelve one
that's a release strategy for twelve one
so most of the things you see in that
section is gonna be postural one so wait
a minute move the following video
posting features to video will be there
[Music]
okay so we're in it so what is going to
be there they import export functions
don't below in a limb in a slightly
limited fashion because they also
required a video object to be really
useful all the way yeah um very much
earlier in this in the session Brian on
the live stream is asking why are we
supporting Microsoft WMA audio WMV video
formats that's that's a window miss
media formats right there the current
list of updated video which is a very
large list is not going to support them
if you find good to do it's not it's not
it's not an issue with with licensing or
is that what is that
with the backends we're using ffmpeg and
the OS decoders encoders but that's
that's our radar we'll get to it if we
can support okay we might have some
friends to talk to about how to get that
to work um okay what an earth is mic
rasca a vaguely heard of that what is
that just an odd name for format what is
it
that's MKV you may have seen that what's
the use for that's a very flexible
format it can support very many what is
the name what is the word mean it sounds
Russian somehow what's that I don't know
I might rush get dolls are those dolls
that fit within dolls okay well as maybe
that's a name it's named after those
okay um I hear somebody on the
livestream is pointing out that in our
examples we should probably have some
ethnically different faces but surely we
can get four examples and we should also
check I assume it works
III think I think faces are happily
pretty easy to deal with they're not
there are other things that are much
harder to deal with that I think I think
they're you know faces you know
eyes nose mouth are all recognizable
that's a minor issue for the stock
photography we're using Charlie um okay
so what will we have checked our video
decoders and dollar video encoders and
your system that's going to give you the
list of containers and all of the
supported decoders and encoders
for the Trifield my gosh okay check keys
okay he's keys of that dollar video
decoder that's gonna be the containers
but for each one of them what is video
it has to be video format I don't know
what it why it says video we are passing
anything that we think may be a video
file to ffmpeg and see if it can decode
it
okay what a mess what does a streaming
video services use today they flip
around depending on what what the you
know it with some QoS stuff and things
what do they do
do you know I mean like whatever lag or
risk you know like what uses that I mean
is it some random I mean are these
different parameter spaces in terms of
you know packet loss versus this versus
battle what why why did why there's so
many of these I haven't checked the
history of all of them but you actually
find files under those encodings as far
as what they're streaming services use I
think they can on equalise most of them
mp4s are the most common ones just think
if we'd lived in different times Betamax
would have survived as well as VHS then
able to even get that Russia gets that
yeah yeah yeah because the fact that
there's so many of these that can
coexist is remarkable to me if I there
isn't an economy of scale and you know
one format winning out is surprising
I've seen the sort of is some kind of
ongoing competition like Google has been
trying to launch licensed free video
formats for some time but somehow the
h.261 consortium with her patents seemed
to have enough momentum that it didn't
topple in at least not yet if she won't
say yeah but I mean again I just don't
understand the diversity here because I
mean you know like like for example for
us do we know properties of these sites
okay let me ask question each one of
these formats presumably has you know
like we could imagine in our knowledge
base having data about these different
formats um like for example I mean it's
just like do they live in you know is
there a five parameter space and these
things are optimizing different things
in that space I mean there are a lot
more of these and there are image
formats there anybody cares about right
I mean image formats these days they're
like two or three that people care about
aren't there
unless something like TIFF is like a
meta format which it is right okay in
any case all right fine so what are we
then what what is the plan here so first
question is why are we not getting a
video we're not getting a video player
in the desktop front end or what was the
deal with that right and so and it is
that getting nearer or is that so far
away no it's it's pretty near but I
think that the high DPI thing sort of
consumed the bandwidth that they had and
it's John is here great yeah it's the
basically you know there are things that
are sequential life here there are
things that we have to finish before
before Saudis team can really begin a
certain set of tax and work we're trying
to finish that stuff on a 12-1 timeframe
so they can have most of the following
release to work on it okay
but so what you're delivering then is
from a file on the desktop machine
you're delivering the our log of our
audio player for video is that correct
well I'm delivering something much more
powerful which is library link for the
front end but then sadi will be able to
use bags to deliver what you're going on
yeah so how does what is the eye framing
of stuff through library link or
whatever it is in the front end it's not
going to be eye framing the I dono
percent now for certain how we're going
to do this but I mean you know the most
primitive scenario would work decently
which is to say just have the library
link stuff send us bitmaps but the point
being that it can all be done you know
in process you know with shared memory
and and that the impassive stuff can be
doing the decoding as well so I mean you
that way we might we might come up with
something better than that but I think
even that would give us really quite a
lot ok so then I'm going to ask the
obvious question could we be running a
web browser inside that given that you
have librarians spraying spray yeah
well so the I mean the easier thing
about a video player is that the
communication is comparatively one-way
right I understand as opposed to having
an image map where it's having to
respond to clicks yeah I mean when when
we did the web browser plugin for Mac OS
where we were very limited on the kinds
of exchanges that we could do I mean
what we did was absolutely crazy what we
did was we actually
indicated bit knots over over w FCP but
then that wasn't even the hard parts
that was just the wow I can't believe it
worked part but the hard part was
dealing with all of the event handling
mouse clicks Keys rows etc etc yeah but
so that's the issue here then okay so
this is a one-way library link to
spraying bitmaps of the blunt end
basically well I mean it's I mean it's
not it's not that there can't be any
interaction it's that you know being the
interaction is you know kind of you know
build it yourself and that you know can
get arbitrarily complex but you know I
will make decisions about what we want
to actually try and ship some okay
all right okay so that's necessary to be
able to play the video in the front end
the processing video has nothing to do
with that right correct so I mean in
other words if you were to take that
file and process it and click on an
external video player you know you could
that would be just fine you could just
see that file be processed externally
correct so long as your functions could
still work yes okay so the video object
points to the video file
okay display to the video player except
that won't work yet um okay video up so
video filter Wow okay yeah those four
function names are just a placeholder
okay but video map so what you're
essentially saying is show me the
position of the tiger in every frame
return so it's like file system map but
it's across video frames so this is
video frame map effectively trapping
across video frames and in general you
might want to do something where you
subsample or you combine frames before
you actually do the processing yeah okay
so then a typical
thing there I see is you get back a time
series which is do two videos have a
sort of metadata that gives I mean some
videos presumably have absolute time
metadata but most videos just have
relative to the beginning of the video
metadata I mean if you you know if
you've got video from some random
security camera
it probably has I don't know whether
there's a standard for this it probably
has a an absolute time except like
things that true you know there are
extended version of exist I think we
discussed it last time I've seen GoPro
for instance documenting their extended
exit so that there are the metadata is
time resolved for each time you can
store specific metadata right um I think
at this point this is really a moving
target it's it's a new need that is
being standardized or even developed not
even close to being standardized okay so
but so does this any of this stuff work
now they were by the way so they were
added this week and video is broken in
today's prototype so no no prototype has
these working but I'm guessing very soon
they're gonna be working yes cool okay
so we do have to work on the design for
these because because this would be
perfectly reasonable to take I mean a
video frame map or whatever it is
whatever we call it video time series
map or something I don't know what the
right name for it is but that's
something that can perfectly will work
in 12:1 you give it a video as a file
and the the
[Music]
and then and then and then it should and
then it can return that digest of the
video based on those things yeah I guess
the discussion Roger and I had is that
is that gonna be sufficient to have
Pross well how how encouraging or
discouraging would it be to have video
objects without the video player
built-in so with every operation people
have to check their result outside of
our system but not necessarily if
they're just processing something and
getting back some digest results they
can be happy people I don't think it's
bad I don't think that's that bad at all
I think we should do that well it's
exciting actually we are continuing with
our development at first anyway the
player is not slowing other development
parts of this plan slow I guess we can
but I would definitely like to have
design discussions event with Roger we
haven't had time to look at these four
functions or more functions that many
ask for processing and I would be happy
to do any design reviews on that and
plan and and continue our development as
I said and then we can decide what parts
of that can be released into a1 um ok
all right but anyway what's the story
with the interface to machine learning
with this done for video yeah but you
know obviously we want to be able to it
encode and decode and there are a lot of
scenarios that you would like to combine
video and audio tracks and so forth we
haven't find much of that yet
I mean the big concern has been dead
let's say to be release this without the
plane will it be mostly a backlash and a
negative experience rather than a
positive this is really positive
I don't know it's super good but but is
it now will it generate more of a
backlash than a positive okay so
actually let's ask the folks on our live
stream that yeah few responses here with
people being pretty interested in this
like being able to analyze brightness
per frame and all sorts of things and
make a make a graph and so on I'm just
looking at some of the comments here um
I'm remembering a blog that Te'o did a
number of years ago where he used some
codes creates a color palette graphs
various oh yeah I remember that
Disney good news yeah over zoom they
touch press out yeah cuz I think that I
mean in my book this will be a super
good 12 to release and it will be
slightly whimpering I think I bring out
some okay listen we could bring it out
but not really tout it just make some
functions available let some people know
about them but not really tell them not
put them not market them that would be
easier for us cuz its yeah this is we
are in prototype we're just developing
everything in system so we're just gonna
merge to master and release rather than
hiding things on their video context and
so forth yeah I think it's better that
way um like a few comments on the
livestream so Ethan is saying image
contents needs work and video contents
for would be fun yep
a lot of work um various comments about
video formats okay um let's see
uncie will give export be improving I
always have memory and slowness issues
even says to look use gift circle to
optimize them I don't know what that is
external pronoun some kind but I mean
I'm I think that there was already in 12
right gif I mean what it we've done
several improvements today like animated
important export Bo forgive for pngs
okay well that'd be interesting to know
if Ethan has tried what's at twelve oh
um Nicola and Ethan are saying please
parallel eyes export video frames is
that doable by us I mean is that so why
wouldn't parallel I see so that would be
using parallel table and so on to do
well comments is that that where would
the the parallelization the question is
who does the bit mapping and the
encoding to make the video frame right
and that could perfectly well be done in
parallel and maybe you're already doing
that Charlie can you comment on that for
those formats a lot of these encoders
need to be encoded in sequence we cannot
paralyze because each frame depends on
the frame before it is that true I mean
and there isn't a way to parallel eyes
and then and then to more or less finish
and then put some name because it's
because the the compression is based on
image dips and things or what yeah but
in video photos I think I think it's
referred to as that format that we have
video frames I haven't looked at that
I'll look at it okay I mean with all
those video formats you'd have to
believe somewhere parallelizable it says
right um
this this video frames seems to be just
exporting to formats such as PNG and I
think that one can be paralyzed yes
although I see okay yeah I mean I Bob on
the live stream is mentioning the
importance of converting all videos to a
standardized format that's what we're
doing for images as well I mean right
we're going to have a standardized
internal representation videos that will
just be consistent independent of what
the external representation is and what
is that internal representation I mean
for images it's just bitmaps basically
interleaved in different ways but what
is it primitives is it doesn't have
compression by default or not images no
images are not compressed and videos I'm
sorry videos our video is always gonna
be out of core there is the data is
gonna be stored on the disk as it is in
the file and then we're gonna be having
decoders to read frames out of them and
then encoders to write the result right
yeah I plan on having an in core video
object so as I understand it video frame
map or what what might be better called
video images Matt it's basically going
to take a function f and apply it to the
image that is each decoded frame of the
video and produce a result correct yes I
would recommend something like video
images map you know map images I don't
know video images Maps something like
that okay so that I understand how that
will work that's very cool punch I mean
we should put that in that's useful
whether or not we have a a I mean like
like for example tayos analysis of all
the Disney movies um for that Disney app
would be then a one-line thing basically
yeah let's take the average color of
each frame in the movie and go ahead
yeah but then the thing is that as soon
as you want a video images map in the
system you want to have introduced video
object and what's gonna be the type
settings of that how it's gonna be the
player playback of the gray blob okay
survive okay and I think what the gray
blob should do is is just you click it
and it should pull up an external video
player which is pretty civilized because
you're not gonna want the video you know
you want a thumbnail anyway right you
don't want a full screen video right
well you might or might not want a full
screen video right in your notebook
right so you know the question of
whether it pulls up to full size in your
notebook or outside your notebook seems
a secondary issue that makes sense yes
so I think it's perfectly fine to just
have you click the video player and for
now it will come up with an external
video player and whatever it opens
QuickTime or whatever it opens for you
um okay so oh one second
um no that Bob was suggesting the exact
same thing I just said no actually what
he's suggesting here which is completely
reasonable is that the video player in
the notebook would show a single frame
from the video as its thumbnail which is
of course a totally reasonable thing and
that's what every video player does the
only difference is when you click that
button does it sing and dance in the
notebook or does it bring up another
window and I think it's absolutely fine
for it to bring up another window what
will they do in the cloud I think this
one project that the player and the
cloud is gonna be much easier to see
yeah easier yeah it'll be yeah I mean
the problem with audio player wasn't the
playing of audio it was the GUI style
did the the the elements that the cloud
notebooks hadn't yet supported in the
GUI right okay so in the case of the
okay so you guys are gonna make a plan
with the cloud people to put whatever
they can put in not sure what the UX is
gonna be it may be remarkably similar UX
where you're basically clicking whatever
it is I don't know but we can prototype
the UX there where the thing initially
shows a thumbnail you click it it
becomes a you know a player in notebook
you can have to resize that player etc
yeah I sort of I don't think that if we
go this route that we're on anywhere
shape form on a November release at all
we're not going to hold up the release
with video so get where you can get in
there put it in experimental experiment
or whatever you want to do you know let
some people play with it but don't you
know we're not gonna hold up the release
for this yep
here help does a file the okay come on
also import a list of images as a video
so in other words assemble a list of
images it's like a video assemble
function that should work that's that's
coming into a1 yes okay that's part of
video encoding thing yep same as
exporting manipulates video will be
entertainment
you mean that exporting in the same
support yeah exporting of a list of
images or exporting you manipulate okay
Niccolo and livestream is saying it
parallelized video frames all the time
just have to define the file names the
head of the export and then use parallel
map the same video frames format that we
talked about if you open it in there ref
page it's basically exporting and
manipulate into a list of pngs for
instance okay but that's there's some
parallel map thing to different file
names I'm confused here do you
understand what what's being said here
what where am I looking at melting a
formats page or am I looking at format -
page formats page video frames video
frames plural yes new and 8 well I have
never used this I'm sure we've used it
plenty of times I've never used it
okay okay Bob is pointing out on the
live stream here is that some decoding
formats are slower than others and
unsuitable for video editing so some
video editors decompress a portion of
the video for everything in cash it and
Brian is saying intelligent caching of
decoded video frames would help
performance hugely a nickel is saying
video frames will give filenames
automatically but does so sequentially
so I haven't quite understood this thing
about parallel versus sequential I think
there's something to understand that
okay alright so look we're clearly gonna
have another discussion about this oh
boy subtitle decoders well that's
obviously something presumably how are
the subtitles stored in a video are they
are they stored as metadata or what well
they're not just composited into the
image are they I mean there's that
there's a separate closed captioning
stream exactly and it could be multiple
of those sometimes they're stored as a
separate file but a lot of times it's
inside of the video and yes it's styled
text so then there are three tracks
there's the video there's the audio and
there's separately so extracting audio
from a video is that something we're
going to be able to do easily yes and
there is can we do that and then formats
do allow for multiple video tracks
multiple audio tracks multiple subtitle
tracks one thing design-wise that we
have to decide is how much we want to
support multiple tracks multiple tracks
of each three of those by default for
instance if we if our video filter
function is working on a video object
that has multiple of those tracks how
how much do we want to support
different functions for different video
audio subtitle tracks to be possible or
do we know this is this is gonna get
messy the design what why isn't this
like layers wasn't it like in images we
have an alpha channel we have this we
have that yeah so maybe open the video
filter rest page in CVS that's the one
that we expect out some yeah okay so if
you just specify a single function we
could say that we are processing all of
the video tracks with that functions
done yeah and then you can I understand
so you're gonna have to be able to
address each track just like you can
address each what are they called and
each channel and them in an image right
so I don't see what the problem with
that is I mean uh in the case of image
limit when we map on two images how do
we address the channels then can we map
onto the Alpha Channel only no no do you
know we we've never thought about that
this is we can color separate color
combined while processing just one of
those channels but none of our functions
supply the channel maybe that's what we
should do with videos as well yep just
separate I agree that here in the
filtering maybe it's easier but then
when you start asking for something like
sample rate of different audio tracks or
sample rate of a of audio tracks in a
video file do you always want to get an
association or a list of different
sample rates for each track where most
of the time the user may be working just
with video files that have a single
audio object to me those are the kinds
of things that we probably need to
discuss and I guess video files with
multiple audio or subtitle are becoming
more and more popular but video files
with multiple video tracks are less
popular yeah I understand because
probably people have translations in the
audio
but yes um or descriptions narration and
things like that right well those are
coming attraction Asuza I mean I would
have thought I don't know and I mean I
don't know whether the channels and the
audio named you know English French
Russian or something or whether they are
just 1 2 3 and you have to know the
channel 11 titles and they could have
languages but none of them are mandatory
I see both both for subtitles and audio
tracks title and language are supported
tags okay all right well this looks very
cool more to discuss about it is
anything else for this I mean we're
clearly running out of time that I'd
like to look at okay DICOM Olga renamed
the OGG file formats OGG Vorbis okay
fine but I'm assume will still accept or
give people August August becoming their
video format now the video container if
you specify I mean it yes you're going
to be assumed to be an audio format okay
but if you say if you have code right
now that reads in an OGG it's still
going to be able to hand it it's
eventually going to read in an organ to
a into a I mean what about mp4 isn't
that doesn't have this had the same as -
am i confused what right now if you
import an mp4 do you get its video which
we don't or do you get its audio track
in 12 currently we don't support mp4 in
12 zero in 12 one you're going to be
getting your video okay fine but we
should be able to have an import element
for mp4 which is just the audio and we
do okay fine and by the way this channel
business
is you know we already have a pattern in
the import elements for picking out
particular channels like but I don't
know HDS and things like this don't we
yes this sub-element video as well okay
it's fine so and we should also make
sure that we we canonicalize languages
and so we can get you know french entity
or something those kinds of things okay
speeding pool and bug fixes okay DICOM
um cool so the next time i get some
random CT scan done hopefully no time
particularly soon I'll be a lot weeded
in here died come dear race what you
want then die come dear because those
are a whole directory of images I see I
see previously I always looked on the
disk and pulled out individual DICOM
images and you're saying DICOM der is
the whole bundle is that right yeah yeah
so that's when you get em rightly see
tease those things um yeah like like
when you when you request them from you
know the hospital or whatever they come
they give you a disc and the disc has on
it some application that is a viewer
right sometimes okay okay
okay fair enough but then usually what
I've done at least I haven't done this
for a while is you go into the directory
and you just find the individual raw
files and you import them yeah you can
do that in I because you're saying the
doer thing would take a whole directory
and import it for example in the slices
instead of getting individual slices you
can I mean normally you import the
slices and you reassemble them into an
image 3d you're saying this is the way
to do that in one step exactly there is
going to be an image 3d element where
you can combine all of the sequences in
one C in one series you can play with by
I think the example is my knee we have
this
okay good there hopefully it's been it's
recovered since it needed to be the okay
all of those I really think I really may
need attention specifically that may
need a short meeting with ed pagan Jose
Jose's here okay and what about the
there's also the the what's it called
Gaul a format do we is that what this is
know that if anything that should be a
separate forma okay but didn't somebody
write a gully importer or if not I I
know somebody and the outside world so
to speak who is prepared to do that
yeah let's discuss that in that nut
discussion
okay attachment rules option what is
that that's the one that says how to
import each of the attachments of an
email or exclude that what do you mean
by each of the attachments like a gift
like this like a named attachments or
what yeah we're gonna be able to say
what element to import from gift from
wave or any other formats basically I've
already designed this once in a separate
meeting it's just on the list okay
alright okay
updates well that's good that's good
because we can use this more generally
then there are new versions of those
Association syntax is gonna be very
useful why one goes to yes definitely
and that that create archive I mean
somehow that relates to a file system
map and so on I would think I mean that
that's returning that's using the same
format so question in file system map
there is a mechanism for nested
associations to represent nested
directories that should presumably be
supported for create archive and extract
archive as well
I see currently we have a flat
association but that file1 file2 could
have directories in them as well well
let me show you what happens with file
system map right the file system map you
can have nested associations okay so the
way it works is you give it a a well
that's really exotic but anyway you give
it an N here so down to level n are
represented by nested associations okay
so here you see index goes to this
that's oh yeah there you see a directory
going to the individual files see what
I'm saying mm-hmm
whereas here because you've given a
certain level spec here this is now
flattening it to use the file the
directory delimiter instead okay with
the individual keys with directory
delimiter but I think it'll be very
useful to be able to if you're
extracting from a whole nested you know
you've got a whole nested subdirectory
structure zip it up you know by
specifying something like this only
makes sense
I think extract archive is gonna benefit
more from this and create archive oh I
agree completely extract archive would
be yeah I mean extract archive so here's
his piece of opera is an operation so
one of the questions is file system map
is used to mapping over an external file
system right now let's say you to
extract archive and you get the contents
of a whole bunch of files arranged in
this hierarchical directory fashion okay
right now file system map only expects
to operate on an external file system
and we don't have a good way of doing
the mapping of this ragged nested
Association structure right but I wonder
whether file system map should actually
be able to be given essentially an in
memory you know Association nested
Association structure that it could do
its same operations on right so right
now file system
it's going in and well actually I think
it's just being given the file names but
I don't you see what I'm saying so I
mean I'm saying the question is you do
you know one thing you can do is extract
onto the disk you get a bunch of files
you go and and just do and I don't even
know how you do that I mean we we don't
have a function right now that doesn't
unzip on the disk either out of core we
don't have an out of core it extract
archive right but if we did an out of
court extract archive and then we passed
the results to file system map it would
be a happy thing right now what we have
here is an extract archive into core
what we do have extract archive cannot
cannot return the file hierarchy but
import of archive formats can give you
file names and those file names could be
nested I think that's that's what you're
yeah I don't think it's going to be
quite right
because if you look at the Association
its keys or the file names so what you
want why why can't extract archive
extract to a nested key structure or
nested Association structure I think it
should I mean otherwise it's losing
information what's it gonna do otherwise
it's just a flat list like agree I think
the mess said yeah
scroll down to their examples I agree
they're nested it's gonna be backwards
incompatible but if you're and if this
goes back to version a well I think that
what we can do there
look worst cases it's changing the
default because file system map if you
say infinity here then then that's the
same thing but it's never going to be
the same thing because I'm sure in
version 8 it was returning a list of
rules not an association right in the
making sense
what is it returning here what the heck
is it returning that's just returning
filenames okay I'm confused we need to
look at this what is that doing it's
just returning a bunch of firemen this
is extracting and archive and then
saving the content into the current
directory oh well
so extract archive is very ok all right
fine
so my statement about how still the
result would be a nested Association no
no it doesn't need to be there's no
point in it being a nested Association
unless extract archive it's pointless
this is fine then you do file system map
across this I think but this is turning
it into a nested directory structure as
specified in the archive okay we need to
have a quick look at these again but you
should make sure that it's compatible
with file system map yep
[Music]
compression level I'm not sure that
level is the right term because isn't it
number like 0.9 or something oh really
yeah oh so it is a level like zoom level
something that's an arbitrary scale run
on my live stream we have a point so
sorry as a string I know I know it's a
sub method option right um Brian our
live stream points out that come things
like thar support symbolic links which I
don't know how we're dealing with
so is there a question on test don't
some of these things literally the zip
allows this doesn't zip allow you to
have keys authentication keys yeah I've
got a run I so um okay
I think we got a little bit more this
stuff utilities here I absolutely put
them in the function depository okay yes
absolutely
please do that I don't know what
canonicalize format does then call it
format name oh so wait a minute the
authentication option was that would be
works to our authentication option is
that correct that's not how we're doing
it now we have been discussing if we are
working with things on servers that have
that need username and password those as
well may need authentication and we need
to have a way of specifying the file
class word separately from the username
password of the server okay fine but use
the authentication option right use the
authentication option the authentication
option can give you gives you it has it
has very rich ability to specify
different kinds of things because there
are all kinds of all kinds of wild
things you might want to specify
authentication it can handle that I
think but you should talk to i mean the
the probably Brad Ashby is the expert
in that okay okay but please use the
authentication option because if you use
that also things like our system
keychain functionality will all work
with it and so on and so on and so on
make sense yeah um and I was going to
make one more point here Oh on our live
stream Ethan is pointing out our cars
made on Mac OS and Linux up others who's
decompressing each other at times I
don't know about that is that a that's
not in the modern world endianness has
become standardized doesn't it pretty
much things like that is there an end
Ian assists sealers IPPs I don't know no
question of that
what's that I said I don't think so okay
so anybody know anything about that well
it's just an issue okay
um Ethan is saying be nice to support
formats like raw are AR is that in the
plan I've certainly seen that point
around okay well it's a full night I've
certainly seen around yep um okay well
sorry we're not going to be able to get
to what was the what was the other thing
we're going to discuss today graphics
and geometry in graphics okay
apologies to those people I will have to
put that on Monday I have a difficult
travel intensive week next week I think
uh let's try and push it on to Monday in
some way um so if we could get that
message to Emma and suchlike that'll be
good sure okay
thank you all very much thank you to
focus on the live stream a lot of great
comments
much appreciated um and see y'all soon